[Music]
after decades of voyaging through
galaxies and science fiction star trek
icon william shatner reached the final
frontier in a rocket built by
billionaire amazon boss jeff bezos with
his blue origin it took leaving this
earth and being blasted into space in
order for the 90 year old to see what
i've been saying for a while
everybody in the world
needs to see
there is mother of earth and comfort but
what you see is black
what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can imagine it's uh i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i just
it's extraordinary extraordinary
and william shatner joins me now william
great to have you on the program thank
you so much for joining piers morgan
unsensitive
deck appears you know when i was young
uh and i've been pretty young i used to
love star trek the tv series and it
taught me in many ways a lot about space
travel and i found it fascinating as
well as entertaining when i watched you
get so emotional
about actually going to space it made me
quite emotional watching you
this guy i grown up with
actually achieving this dream and
finding it so breathtakingly moving what
was it like for you
well that you know you've asked an
interesting question
i was emotional but and you were
emotional what were you emotional about
i was really emotional about watching a
guy who when i was young was this great
tv icon i loved star trek and i learned
about space travel really through the
show
and then to see you this fictitious
character that i knew from television
the real man going up in space and being
so moved i thought i just found that
very moving yes
i i i'm glad to hear that but
for me
the emotion wasn't like oh i'm up in
space and i i played a space
commander so many years ago
for me
when i look back at earth and i've only
discovered this hours after when i came
down i'm thinking why am i so emotional
and what i discovered for myself was
that i was grieving for what we've done
to this
earth this tiny little rock and and you
see the tiny little rock
i could see the beginning of the
curvature of the earth i could make a
circle and do the circumference of the
earth that's how tiny we're
insignificant this insignificant rock
with these insignificant ants on the
rock
and yet it's beautiful and it's our life
and we're destroying it and i didn't
really comprehend
what my
tears were for
until i had time to assess it and then i
realized i was grieving
for the earth and what we've done and
how because as you know yeah i was going
to say on that point i mean i think
there are two things we've done it seems
to me we've slowly ruined the planet you
know physically ruined it with our
consumption but also it seems to me that
we've we've lost a lot of people lost
all sense of perspective and that maybe
when you were up in space looking down
and seeing this tiny thing earth that we
need to get back to
common sense to a sense of perspective
about what really matters in life would
you agree with that
well that's philosophically right that's
correct that's like a really good idea
in the midst of driving an electric car
somewhere
that that that's a great idea
what i saw
is the enormity of what we've done
what we've done to five billion years of
evolution and and all these beautiful
things that have evolved and are gone
forever
five billion years brought whatever it
is is now extinct
it's gone
and
dimly in my mind i was looking back at
earth and grieving not only for the
things that are gone
but the things that are going
and in the very near future the things
that
will go right and it was all that we are
doing nothing
about
what this tsunami
you know that apparently in hilo some
years ago there was a tsunami and the
people didn't recognize it and the water
goes out apparently and they're the
people oh look at that the water's gone
out there's fish there they were not
aware that this giant wave was coming to
hawaii to kill a lot of people there's a
giant wave coming our way we see aspects
of it now with the all the storms and
and and droughts and things
but that's nothing compared to what our
children are going to face in the next
several years prince william um who's
actually big on the environment but
prince william was quite critical of
your trip and the other what he calls
tourism space travel trips he thinks
it's billionaires running around wasting
time and money they should be focused on
more important things what did you think
of that
well you know that's that's
that's yeah you know in if you look at
it yes that's true there's all that
energy going to to to go up and come
down
but bezos's idea
is to get polluting industries
up into the sky
and
and let them pollute you know 300 miles
above us
and and and try and uh bring the earth
back to what it was it's a beautiful
idea when i was talking to him i said
but that's going to take a hundred years
and we don't have a hundred years and he
said
and this is what the prince should
understand
you've got to have hope
without hope you have nothing so
we're cling to a hope but we've got to
do something about the carbon dioxide
and the methane to say
you know two things that are polluting
us well you talk of hope i can only say
that if when i get to 90 i hope i look
half as good as you do william shatner
piers you've got the bone structure to
be 102 and look as handsome as you are
today
it's fantastic to talk to you uh
honestly you're one of my tv heroes and
a great guy and i really appreciate you
joining the show tonight thank you very
much
thank you pleasure to talk to you
what a man what a legend
captain james t kirk
you